Indian Lions Australian crocodiles
Russian brown bears and Siberian tigers
david quammen considers the past present
and future of these man-eating predators
in the new book monster of god the
c-span school bus caught up with the
author in Bozeman Montana last week this
event is about an hour okay I want to
thank you all for coming out here
tonight for this special event and I
want to thank managing to santee for
hosting it here at her store the country
bookshelf and showing the continued
pluck encourage and good business school
it takes to keep alive an independent
bookstore but also like to thank the
c-span crew for coming all the way out
here to Bozeman Montana to film this
event and most of all I'd like to thank
david quammen for the honor of
introducing him here tonight and a great
honor it is david quammen is one of the
finest science and natural excuse me
nature writers in the world today he has
been warded the national magazine award
for essays and criticism for his work in
magazines like Esquire Harper's and
outside he's also picked up a national
excuse me an Academy Award for
literature national academy of arts and
letters in 1977 and that was where his
work in books he's written for of
fiction books five non-fiction books
including titles like the acclaimed
flight of the iguana and song the dodo
in his latest work monster of God he's
taken on rather daunting task which is
to chronicle the long complex and often
bloody relationship between humankind
and large predators to sort of a
love-hate and occasionally eat
relationship now American wild lands we
do a lot of work trying to protect the
wildlife corridors that animals travel
between protected areas and to help
alleviate the inevitable problems that
occur when a busy roadway or highway
bisex one of those corridors so I can
speak for some experiences when I tell
you how difficult it can be to answer
that question why is it so important
that we protect while
species what's going to be lost if they
go extinct and that task becomes
quadruple e difficult when you're
talking about large predator like a
grizzly bear which meets you out there
he might be in a lot of trouble David
answers that question in Monster of God
he not only does it in a scientific way
and from an ecological perspective he
finds answers in some very unexpected
places very deep in human mythology and
human mind in the heart and the soul
showing us just how important these
animals have been in our development as
a species ourselves and just how much
it's going to be lost if they go extinct
in essence may be saying that learning
to live appearance tigers crocodiles and
bears the motors part would be a process
of learning to live at peace with
ourselves only a very adventurous mind
would have taken on a task like that and
only a very fine writer like David would
have pulled it off with dave is more
than just a fine writer that's all of
you who know him will surely breathe
he's also just a really great guy and
those of us lucky enough to have seen
him in action at his recent wedding
reception will also testify he's a
vastly underrated dancer so please
welcome David Kwan
thank you thank you Michael I think I'm
gonna mess with this a little bit is
this is this for a TV or is this also
for us to be able to hear in the room
here both okay in that case does that
help any is that any better in terms of
sound I want to get in your faces a
little bit up in the up in the bleachers
and so we're all sort of able to hear
each other Michael Reagan appears here
tonight courtesy of the mr. winkle
international enterprises corporation
and I really appreciate him introducing
me and I appreciate all of you coming
out tonight it was about a year ago just
about this time that a lot of us were
here together at the country bookshelf
for a different sort of event that we
called one fine page to celebrate what a
wonderful and precious community
resource this book story is and it's
nice to be back and the bad news is i'm
going to read more than a page tonight
and thanks also to scott pearson into
the c-span crew for being here and being
interested in what we're doing here
tonight because of because this is a
television event i thought maybe i
should what oh yes not just michael
regan but also american wild lands for
everything they do and for lending us
along with mr. winkle michael regan
tonight and for being the ones who
really made the connection between the
country bookshelf and me and c-span so
thanks very much to american wild lands
for that and because this is a
television as well as community event
tonight it occurred to me that i should
wear a tie so i'm doing that but since
we're all friends here i'm wearing it
discreetly in my pocket
I want to tell you a little bit about
this book and then I'll read some short
bits of it it's the subject subject of
the book Michael mentioned a bit of this
the subject of the book is a group of
animals to which I've given the the
label for convenience alpha predators
and that's not a that's not a scientific
category it's not an ecological label
it's an arbitrary label that I picked
and what I what I mean by it is that
particular group of animals that are big
enough fierce enough solitary enough
such that a single individual of one of
these species can and occasionally does
kill and eat a human and and thereby the
subtitle of the book which is the
man-eating predator in the jungles of
history and mind and while I'm at it
I'll thank my friend Tim Cahill for
without permission allowing me to to
poach on the concept of the jungles of
the mind tim has spent a lot of time in
the jungles of the mind to so these
alpha predators there is a short list of
species that belong to this category it
includes the lion the tiger the the
polar bear the brown bear including our
grizzly bear the leopard the Nile
crocodile in Africa the saltwater
crocodile in Australia and southeastern
Asia the Komodo dragon the great white
shark the Ganges shark are probably now
the Cougar the mountain lion is
reentering this category as it starts to
get bolder again and occasionally a taxi
human a few giant snakes the reticulated
python the Anaconda and probably a
couple of other species of crocodilians
a couple of other species of sharks and
that's about it those are the alpha
predators those are the only species on
earth big enough and fearsome
such that a single animal will
occasionally take a human I haven't
included wolves in this category I
haven't included jackals hyenas piranhas
and a number of other species because
there's their social species their pack
hunters their school predators but a
single individual wolf no more than a
single individual piranha is not a
serious threat to to a human what I was
interested in and and what I've examined
in the book is these these species their
status in the world their future if any
on this planet and also their
relationship their relationships with
with us with human beings and those
relationships are complicated and
ambivalent and go back a long way go
back at least a million years ever since
we've been a species we have we have
faced these these creatures as we being
potential prey they've reminded us that
we're just another flavor of meat they
have reminded us that we're part of the
natural world we're not separate from
the natural world we're not above the
natural world we're part of it we're
part of a food chain and I talk in the
book about the food chain of power and
glory that that its concept that comes
out of the Old Testament the book of Job
where there is one of these creatures
called Leviathan that serves to remind
job and to remind the rest of humanity
that humans are are not the greatest
species in the world they're not even
second to Yahweh to the Lord but we
ranked third on that food chain of power
and glory after Yahweh then Leviathan
then comes job and other humans so I
argue that these species have played an
incredibly important role for me
years or more in in the process of human
self definition in the way we understand
our role in the natural world and that's
one of the reasons I wanted to go into
the subject I focus in the book on for
particular cases of four species or
populations of big predators in four
different parts of the world and in each
case also on the native people the
indigenous people who share landscape
with that population of animals the four
cases are the Asiatic Lion in a little
patch of protected forest called the
gear forest gir in western India people
think Tigers usually when you say India
but there is a subspecies of lion
panthera leo persica the persian line or
the Asiatic Lion that survives in this
little forest Enclave in western India
and it shares that it shares that forest
with a native people of cattle and
buffalo herders known as mauled ari's
who live in the forest pasture there
Buffalo and their cows in the forest and
deal with these lions in a very intimate
way so that's the first case second case
is the saltwater crocodile in northern
Australia where it shares landscape and
riparian habitats with Aboriginal people
a couple of different language tribal
groups of Aboriginal people saltwater
crocodile is the biggest and probably
the fiercest species of crocodile on the
planet third case is the brown bears of
the Carpathian Mountains in Romania I'll
talk a little bit more about that but is
unexpected as it is there live in the
carpathian mountains in central romania
five thousand brown bear more than 5,000
brown bear by latest count something
like 50 450 500 Ursus arctos same
species as Grizzly in Romania of all
places which which most of us if we
thought about it at all would probably
think of as blighted industrialized
Eastern Bloc post-communist nation and
it is that but it's also got these
mountains with this
great habitat and some peculiar
political and historical circumstances
that lead to the fact that there are
there is a population ten times the size
and ten times the density of the bear
population of the Greater Yellowstone
Ecosystem living in the highlands of
Romania the fourth case is the Siberian
tiger in the Russian Far East
particularly in an area of mountains
called the sikhote-alin mountains north
of Vladivostok again very wild very cold
very good habitat roughly 300 Siberian
tigers also known as a more Tiger
because it's part of the drainage of the
amor river live there and share
landscape with a native people called
the OODA gay who are a Tungus Manchurian
language group they look like a
Manchurian people they're certainly not
Russian the most traditional of them
live as hunters and trappers in a couple
of different River drainages including
the beacon river and share landscape
there with the Siberian tiger so in the
book I look at in particular those four
cases I also explore some ideas about
the relations between big predators and
humans the question of whether they have
a future on this planet and their
importance to us through the centuries
through the millennia their importance
not just in biological scientific terms
but also in in mythic terms in aesthetic
terms in spiritual terms as reflected in
epic literature in Scripture book of Job
the Old English poem Beowulf with its
Manning predator named Grendel the Epic
of Gilgamesh with its managing predator
named Humbaba and a number of other high
cultural sources including the alien
movies during Sigourney Weaver
I want to read a couple of short
sections not because these sections are
necessarily self-contained but just to
give you a bit of the flavor of some of
the different parts of the book first
bit i'll read is about a page and a half
long it's near the beginning of the book
it's in a section a larger section
titled once there were lions and it's
the beginning of my dialing in on the
subject of the asiatic lion in the gear
forest in western india the teak trees
are bare of leaves and powdered with
tawny dust the acacia's and Banyon's are
dusted to the whole forest is flocked
like broccoli tempura parched with heat
and drought thirsty for monsoon it's
late May which in this part of the world
is late summer as dawn light begins
seeping in the tropical darkness fades
to a pallet of umber done tan and other
dull variants of brown even the Peacocks
asleep in their treetop roosts tales
folded offer no flash of color night
doesn't belong to them not in the wild
peacocks do business by visual display
whereas night stalkers rely on seeing
before being seen on acute hearing and
on smell the smell of water the smell of
fear the smell of blood through this
sepia landscape walks a sepia animal
ghostly along the side of a forest road
it's an improbable creature a lion in a
country fame for tigers if someone were
watching it might seem translucent and
incorporeal holographic projected here
into western India by laser gimmickry
but no one is watching and the animal is
real it has substance and heft it's a
native Dennison of a place known as gear
the last natural refuge of panthera leo
persica the Asiatic Lion
the road dust which is fine like ground
coriander and inches deep takes the
marks of the Lions big for toad pause
pugmarks of such size generally indicate
an adult male so picture him that way a
large Tom with a sparse main maybe the
main is blackish setting off his face
against all the brown imagine a loose
confident gate his belly hangs low his
shoulders rise in sync like Pistons each
step is placed soundlessly if a lion
strides through a forest and no one is
there to see him is he still kingly the
pug marks say yes I go on to I go on to
talk a bit about the the idea of lions
being kingly and the role that they came
to play as sort of archetypal enemies
opponents to various leaders in the
ancient world as sort of representative
beasts or monsters in the archetypal
hero versus beast stories and historical
situation so there were people like
Usher bonner paul Washer nasser Paul
Assyrian Kings Tutankhamun in Egypt and
others who who made their bones by
killing lions that was one of the things
that seems to be important no
testosterone addled young men going out
to kill a lion there's still a bit of
that around I'm going to bounce to
northern Australia to the Northern
Territory of Australia where there is a
large Aboriginal reserve called Arnhem
Land the north eastern quarter of the
Northern Territory its tropical
Australia it's beautiful wild landscape
with wild rivers lined with mangroves
filled with saltwater crocodiles the
crocodiles in this area because the
saltwater crocodile
is the premium animal for crocodile
leather in the world that has that
misfortune saltwater crocodiles were
heavily harvested just after World War
Two all during the 1940s 50s in the 60s
hunters with new high-tech gear meaning
high-powered rifles battery-powered
beams motor boats went up the rivers of
northern Australia and shot up a lot of
saltwater crocodiles harvested their
skins and exported them for the leather
trade and something like 80,000
crocodile skins were exported from the
Northern Territory in a short period of
years at the end of the 1950's and so
these this species was nearly killed off
in northern Australia and then Australia
first the Northern Territory and then
the country of Australia put some
protection on it shut down the trade
eventually it got on the site tease
appendix one that prohibited
international trade in saltwater
crocodile skins and because the habitat
was still good and because crocodiles
tend to reproduce quickly laying
clutches if so it what's here that's
back so it's pretty good check now all
predators in the world that's insulted
drop it off is one of those who has the
best chance to survive into the mid term
maybe the long term the recovery has
been good enough that a few years ago
the the government began to allow
commercial harvest again of crocodiles
from the wild they they first allowed
egg harvest they allowed Aboriginal
people and some white people to go out
and bust open crocodile nests on the
high banks of the rivers gently take the
eggs and bring them back into captivity
hatch them in the captivity rear them up
to the age of two or three thereby
getting around the fact that crocodile
hatchlings in the wild have a very very
low survival rate and then reintroduce
some crocodiles to the wild so that
that's part of what helped now they're
also allowing
some harvest of adult crocodiles in
particular they're letting Aboriginal
people do this with semi traditional
means and because I had some contacts in
Arnhem Land and had made a couple of
trips there eventually I got the chance
to go on an evenings crocodile
harpooning trip I had met a fellow named
Jackie aderall who was an Aboriginal
middle-aged fellow who knows so much
about crocodiles and crocodile harvest
that they call him the professor and I'd
heard about him from a crocodile
biologist who said oh if you're going up
to to man and grita which is this little
community on the north coast of
Australia near the mouth tompkinson
River he said you've got to look up the
professor Jackie a draw so finally I
found Jackie he's a guy he's about 5
foot one or five foot two skinny big
head of curly hair and he looks for all
the world like Chuck Berry he's got a
very sort of a mischievous smile and
speaks kind of a pidgin English and
speaks a couple of different Aboriginal
languages and he agreed to let me go
with him and a couple of younger fellows
when they went out crocodile hunting in
a little aluminum dinghy the younger
fellows were members of something called
the jelq Rangers which was kind of an
adult I don't know what you'd call it it
was a rotary or an adult boy scout group
or something anyway it was a it was a
group that had been formed to to begin
to recapture some of their traditional
skills and and to find ways to make make
some money for the community while doing
that the word Joe dje lk in their
language translates as caring for
country first I went out with them
during the day to help collect crocodile
eggs and we opened a few nests always
kind of watching each other's back
because female crocodiles the mothers
guard these eggs and they don't like it
when you you bust a nest open and take
the eggs away
so we harvested some eggs we put them in
some Rubbermaid coolers we started down
the river in this aluminum boat and
these eggs were so close to hatching
when we opened the nests that they
started hatching in the coolers just
from the noise of the engine and kind of
the mutual jiggle of being in these
coolers together so the whole cooler
loads went off like a pan of popcorn and
we ended up having all these very very
cute little newly hatched baby
crocodiles by the time we got back to
man and Rita and then we went out by
night on this outing we're after adults
we carry an electric beam two 12-volt
batteries several shanks of rope a wide
role of cellophane tape an old rifle
assorted dull knives two spools of
parachute cord and a harpoon we're also
equipped with a box of brass harpoon
points each with an eyelet for attaching
cord for dinner we've got hot dogs which
we eat cold at a quiet Anchorage along
the lower river while waiting for
darkness the moon is a day short of full
rising dimly behind a phlegmy layer of
clouds before proceeding would connect
the beam to a battery and test it Jackie
directs us to put all the gear in order
gasps carboys to the rear spare battery
to the rear box of ropes in front rifle
to the rear everything else stowed
neatly so that the floor of the dinghy
is clear things may get hectic then we
motor upstream to the liver liverpool's
junction with the tompkinson the
liverpool was a larger River a young
Ranger named Randy Jabbar book sits
cross-legged on the bow deck Alastair is
at the children Jackie stands forward
feet placed wide a commanding figure
though barely larger than a child and as
ready as Queequeg to engage the prey
Randy sweeps the banks ahead with his
beam scanning for crocodile eyes shine
the long shaft of light appears smoky
blue against the green wall of mangroves
in the brown water dodging here dodging
there it probes the shoreline lingering
briefly in co
moves behind logs amid the cover of
drowned snags anywhere a crocodile might
hang for a nights feeding Jackie watches
we all watch we see many sets of paired
orange dots but in most cases as we
glide closer engine throttled low they
proved to be juveniles only three or
four feet in length small jackie says
and waves Alistair onward the river is
lit with eyes lining each bank like
highway reflectors we investigate them
one by one a small krokodil of another
small one small again but now jackie
rigs the harpoon fitting a brass point
onto the socket and holds it ready with
the cord pinched along the shaft we
spotlight several lunkers which slinko
sink away as we come near it's spooky
that such a big animal can vanish so
quietly so effortlessly while still
lingering somewhere beneath the boat but
crocodiles don't survive to adulthood by
being stupid at least not as stupidity
is measured within their dim perilous
world just when I'm beginning to
envision a long evening of feudal
approaches jackie slams his harpoon into
the water nothing much happens he draws
back the shaft the brass point is gone
the cord has paid out a few yards but it
seems to be tangled among the roots of a
mangrove my impression is that jackie
has missed he knows better he probes
with a shaft toward the apparent side of
the snarl as though trying to retrieve a
snagged lure he shifts the angle of
tension on the cord while Alistair
steadies the boat then he pulls firmly
easily drawing in the cord hand over
hand until to my amazement up comes the
head of large angry crocodile the
harpoon point is buried in neck muscle
just behind its brain for 20 minutes
Jackie plays it like a 500 pound catfish
when the croc consists violently he lets
it run
when the croc rests Jackie reclaims the
initiative slowly cranking in line
meanwhile we drift silently on the tom
consents current the night is warm the
mosquitoes know we're here jackie speaks
in a whisper either from reverence or
more likely to avoid exacerbating the
crocodiles sense of alarm at an
opportune moment as the crocodile given
up pause together it's wind the signals
aren't obvious at an opportune moment
Jackie asks me to pass him another
harpoon point Randy rigs the cord and
with Jackie raising the Crocs head back
into view Rams home the second strike
the crocodile was now double tethered
and nearly hopeless within a few minutes
we've got it beside the boat the voice
of sobriety in my brain says now what
Jackie lassos its upper jaw with the
loop ended rope the loop tightens down
at that characteristic narrow point
behind the bulbous nose with the upper
jaw held the lower jaw remains a gape
exposing rows of spiky teeth and the
gurgly pink ma at first I mistake this
for a failed try thinking that the
intent was to catch both jaws together
but no it's exactly what Jackie wants
cinching the upper jaw gives a tight
grip snagged among teeth cinching both
would allow the rope to slip off the
snout still the mouth remains free to
slam shut on anything within reach the
crocodile hisses a scary but piteous
sound expressing both rage and
exhaustion Alastair takes up the rifle
an old bold action 22 from the arms
corporation of the Philippines I hand
him a single bullet from the pocket load
that for some reason I've been assigned
to carry jackie and randy hall on the
noose rope hoisting the crocodiles head
against the gunnel the boat has become a
crowded place Alastair puts the muzzle
to the Crocs brain the gun jams
alastair works the bolt to clear it he
tries again the single small pop sounds
almost trivial the shallows slap against
the deep quiet of the night but to the
crocodile it's not trivial the animal
flinches releasing another guttural hiss
like the air coming out of a punctured
truck tire now only now Jackie says
seven foot he's close but too
conservative the eventual measurement
will be 238 centimeters more like seven
foot ten it's a female the belly skin
looks good though not premium probably
grade to the meat will go to the people
of man and grita it proves to be a long
harsh instructive evening on the river
we harpoon two more crocodiles of
roughly the same size one is released
alive no simple task believe me because
jackie has noticed a flaw in its tail
the mild harpoon wound in the thick of
its neck isn't life-threatening and
Jackie sees no reason to kill a good
healthy animal with a commercially
negligible skin the other is an
eight-footer a strong tenacious animal
that requires two harpoon lines a snout
noose a length of parachute cord holding
the mouth closed two shots from the
rifle pithing the brain with my leather
man blade and then pithing again with a
longer knife throughout all this I do my
best to be helpful I do my best to stay
out of reach of the jaws and out of line
of the rusty unpredictable rifle I do my
best to reconcile sympathy for the
crocodiles with sympathy for the people
whose tradition and needs dictate
hunting them i arrived late and
exhausted back at my lodging room
outside man and grita peel off my filthy
clothes let them drop on the floor and
sleep it all seems like a lurid dream
but when I wake the next morning I find
splatters of dried crocodile
on the inside surfaces of the lenses of
my classes now Romania a section let's
see how long of a section should I read
from there in in Romania as I say there
are these 5,400 brown bears why does
Romania have 5,400 brown bears partly
because they've got very good habitat
oak and beech forests that produces a
lot of massed food acorns and other nuts
partly because the Romanian forest
department has a tradition stretched all
through the 20th century of doing fairly
good long rotation forestry that
preserved that habitat partly because
the forest department supplementally
feeds these bears and that's probably
the single most important reason they
push a lot of food into into this
ecosystem essentially to farm bears to
grow bears there are 22 hundred
different hunting areas each has a
particular game keeper who knows that
the 15 or 20 or 24 bears in his area and
each gamekeeper is frequently putting
out bushels and bushels of rotten apples
of plums at plum harvest time of bear
chow of corn cobs and occasionally a
dead horse and there they're feeding
these bears and raising these bears for
commercial hunting and bears bear trophy
skins are now an important export
product from Romania hunters pay real
significant cash for the privilege of
coming into Romania sitting in a little
blind overlooking one of these feeding
stations just about 50 meters away and
shooting a bear and taking home the the
rug the skin but that's since the the
end of communism in 1989 before 1989
there was only one person who hunted
bears in Romania and that was Nicolae
Ceausescu the dictator
he fancied himself a great bear hunter
and essentially arrogated all of the
hunting privileges in the entire country
to himself occasionally he he took some
cronies bear hunting with him people
from the Communist Party the
nomenclature ax in Romania or a visiting
dignitary like Muammar Qaddafi one
gamekeeper told me a story about church
SQ and Qaddafi going out one day and
blowing away everything they saw so he's
gone and not much lamented people in
Romania now referred to him as in Phuket
tool which is Romanian for the shot one
so he finally got his but until that
happened he killed an inordinate number
of bears the the highlands of Romania
are also occupied by shepherds millions
of sheep and thousands of shepherds who
pasture those sheep on the high Meadows
during the summer in these little
shepherd camps where they base
themselves milk the sheep make cheese
from from the sheep's milk and I wanted
to talk to some of those people as many
of them as I could about their their
relationship with the bear their their
feelings about the bear the difficulties
from their point of view of trying to
make a living raising sheep in brown
bear habitat partly because I was
interested in in something that again
I've given it a label I've called it the
Muskrat conundrum it's the problem that
exists in ecosystems around the world of
the fact that big predators are
dangerous inconvenient and expensive and
the people who pay the costs of big
predators janely generally are the rural
people the poor people the native people
who live on the landscape farming
raising livestock living in the forest
and and with very little
margin very little in the way of
political power of material resources
there's there are the people who come
face to face with the big predators most
of the time they pay the most of the
costs whereas most of the benefits are
enjoyed by people like us on the other
side of the world although we have our
own alpha predators in this in this
ecosystem but but generally the the
aesthetic the spiritual benefits of the
fact that Siberian tigers and Asiatic
lions still exist most of those benefits
are enjoyed by people who have the
luxury of enjoying them at a distance
most of the costs are paid by the people
close up I label that the Muskrat
conundrum because of because of some
work by a predator-prey ecologist named
Paul Arrington who studied muskrat in
mink interactions in Iowa in the 1940s
and 50s and found that most of mink prey
upon muskrats and arrington found that
most of the muskrats that become the
prey of mink are those are essentially
the homeless muskrats the marginalized
muskrats the muskrats that are less
competitive than others that don't have
good territories muskrats are
territorial and and aren't able then to
see prime habitat they're the ones that
get picked off by the mink so it's the
it's the homeless that's disempowered
it's the marginalized muskrats who pay
the cost with their lives of mink
predation so I label this whole
phenomenon the Muskrat conundrum how do
we as world society find a way to more
equitably redistribute the costs and the
benefits of big predators I say that
after after learning some of the
economics of sheep raising in Romania I
set off on an informal survey of my own
with a venturesome young translator name
Cyprien chip Pavel I set off on a series
of hikes into the high country we climb
steep wooded slopes above the mountain
roads above the trails following hoof
prints and sheep [ __ ] toward the alpine
meadows where Shepherds spend the summer
sometimes we carry simple provisions red
deer sausage peanuts raisins chocolate
as well as sleeping bags in a tent
sometimes we carry gifts fresh oranges
cigarettes pint bottles of a Romanian
plum brandy called palinka for the
shepherds usually we carry walking
sticks for defense against the dogs big
dangerous Romanian Shepherd dogs that's
another part of the reason they've got
rough equilibrium between sheep and
brown bears we see some gorgeous
landscape mountain lakes stony ridges
and Peaks swales of verdant grass
fog-shrouded expanses of krumholtz and
Heather all of it chilly and wet even at
the height of what down in the lowlands
is a summer drought we talk with dozens
of nut hard general spirited men we're
welcomed often with warm hospitality
candid comments log seats beside a
cookfire hot mamaliga which is Romanian
polenta grainy and yellow served as a
steaming paste and freshly made cheese
of three traditional kinds were de which
is sweet and crumbly tell ameya which is
salty like feta but easily sliced and
bronze adieu sweet and smooth packed for
market in cylinders sewn from fir bark
rarely we face the cold truculence of a
camp boss who wants no visitors and no
palaver among the many things I discover
is that this research regimen so rich
and exercise cold mountain air and
cheese may be bad for my cholesterol
count but is highly agreeable to my
disposition and then I say I learned
something of how Shepherds field towards
bears they visit a number of shepherds I
tell me I've had a couple of losses this
year to bear a couple of losses to wolf
but really that's part of the deal
that's part of the bargain where can you
go what I hear from one Shepherd where
can you go and not seeing bear so you
know this forest the forest that he used
to pasture barren what difference does
it make it's all part of the world as
far as he's concerned
is a let's see I describe how some of
these different cheeses are made and
I'll skip through that but I say there's
one gauge of cheesecloth for tell ameya
a different gauge for cash which is the
bland intermediate stage toward bronzer
de Bourgh doof in a second Hut in one of
these camps under towels rest many large
rounds of cosh hefty and squat they'll
be held for a week and then put through
a grinder to make the bronze ax which is
then packed into pig bladders for
long-term storage or else tamped into
those fir bark tubes for market neeku
the shepherd boss i'm talking to
shepherd boss is called a bocce aneek
who serves us generous samples they're
always serving you samples of cheese
when you go into these camps he serves
as tell ameya and bronze ax and wada
along with the pile of salt for putting
edge to the irda sweetness plus slabs of
cold mamaliga sliced like meat loaf
we're joined by another fellow and a
handsome weather tanned woman who seemed
to be here on a Saturday visit from the
valley seeing my gusto for Nico's
product the fellow jokes to me in
Romania in Romanian bronzer de Bourgh
doof that stuff is good for a man yeah
he raises his forearm big and stiff as a
Stallions penis and knocks on the door
makes you hard the woman rolls her eyes
and swats him as good as viagra I asked
in English global citizen he recognizes
the word viagra no bronzer forget your
fancy American drugs Romanian cheese
will do fine we express our thanks and
hike on later in the afternoon on
another stretch of ridge we encounter
niku and three of his Shepherds still
agitated after chasing off some gypsies
who tried to steal a few horses there's
a lot of anti gypsy sentiment still in
Romania watch out for those bastards as
you hike down through the woods one
Shepherd warns they'll Rob you too as I
say gypsies suffer from lingering
prejudice in Romania but today's episode
at least as niku recounts it helps fuel
the bias his parting wisdom to me
nevermind bears and wolves gypsy
predation is more troubling to the
Shepherd I visit a few more shepherds
and then come to this about a three page
section not many miles away on another
high slope above the mean Valley it's
called vallejo Raya means mean valley we
roused from his afternoon nap another
elderly Bochy Shepherd boss nearly deaf
with a smile brightened by brown eyes
and golden sizers his name is Ian
patrika and he's got four hundred sheep
up here tended by for shepherds where
are you from he asks in a cordial shout
bra job says ship and I say America both
of which seem inconceivably distant to
the man lost my hearing back when I
worked for the Postal Service he
explains hollering above the din of his
deafness from driving a truck a drafty
one through the cold winters sheep
losses maybe two or three a year that's
two bears and another ten two wolves
last year there was a big red bear it
took a couple of sheep three years ago
we had six bears up here he would calls
but the dogs did their job five years
ago once Shepherd got injured and went
to the hospital because he tried to stop
a bear the moral as our hosts briskly
takes it is don't upset the bear if your
dogs can't stop him let the beasts have
what he wants say what's the current
price of bread down there having retired
from the postal service seven years ago
with a poultry pension and spent the
subsequent summers up in Shepherds camps
he evidently gets hungry for news who's
going to win the election if they
privatize all the factories what will be
left for Romania this leads me to a
question about Ceausescu toward whom the
Deaf Bochy harbors no post-communist na
chale nostalgia ciao Ches quiero he
killed a lot of people chip translates
at normal volume somebody else kill him
when you're making good you find good
when you make bad you find bad
what's a cheese he stirs up a fresh pot
of mamaliga and then dumps it out hope a
soft mound of corn mush on a bare wooden
table beside it he sets a bowl of
bronzer from which we each take a few
cheesy nuggets pressing them inside a
handful of warm mamaliga and then
shaping the whole thing like a snowball
around a rock we put our golden spheres
into the fires embers for 10 minutes of
slow roasting this simple delicacy is
known by Romanian Shepherd's as bulls
toasted half crisp on the outside raked
from the coals broken open each ball is
a corn sandwich filled with molten
cheese you haven't tasted the Carpathian
ether nor begun to understand what might
draw man to these high severe places
until you've had bulls from a shepherd's
fire washed down with buttermilk and a
nip of cheap pálinka eon john is a
common name in Romania it seems to be
common or still among the aged
shepherding class in two weeks of
walking the highlands I encounter more
yawns than I can keep straight one man
whose unforgettable among them is eon
Dinka 67 years old and not a Boche not a
boss not a cheese maker merely a
shepherd still climbing out of camp each
day with his flock I find him on a patch
of meadow near the transfagarasan ards
above a switchback curve just south of
the Transylvanian pass he wears a
lambskin hat a wool jacket another
jacket atop that one and rubber boots he
carries a staff a small day bag over his
shoulder and a silver pocket watch
despite several missing teeth he looks
years younger than his age shepherding
it's like a virus he tells me Jovi Lee
he's up here because he likes it can't
resist it not because of need after
retirement from the forest department
nine years ago he returned to what he'd
done is a boy it's late season now he
says and the sheep are giving less we're
milking them only twice a day will stay
till mid-september he says then back
down to the village below
a two day walk I asked about bear
troubles oh yes he says down in the
village a bear sometimes come from the
rating with terrible force breaks into
Corral's takes pigs or chickens and up
here among the Sheep occasionally here
too yes but today yawn Dinka isn't
concerned no bears or wolves nearby he
declares with the confidence of a man
who knows intimately his own little
patch of mountain side which predator is
more troublesome I asked wolf or bear
horse he answers unequivocally wolves
are smarter sure they lurk they move
like thieves but bears worse bring more
danger and damaged one bear a blackish
read animal with white neck markings
took a sheep and three donkeys in a
single night would it be better I asked
if there were no bears at all well
better for him yes it would be but the
bear it spewed wobba paddle ye the
treasure of the forest if you you if you
lose this you lose the treasure he says
a forest without bears it's empty not
all shepherds see it that way I tell him
he agrees noting that most people who
claim to like bears our gentle folk they
live far away he says with no bear
troubles of their own easy for them
shepherds plain men at work in the
mountains don't enjoy such distance
their attitude tends to be lon ie Buck
who were she to hell with the Bears here
it is again then the Muskrat conundrum
yawn Dinka doesn't call it by that label
of course nor does he draw any parallels
between the predator problems of
romanian shepherds and those of
vulnerable marginalized rural people
elsewhere he doesn't even explain why
despite living the life of an
unsheltered muskrat himself he holds a
more appreciative view of the creature
that plays the role of the mink he's
simply a man of Tran
cendant and generous spirit as we sit
talking the neck bells on his leadership
told soothingly clunk clunk clunk ax in
the rhythm of their waddle across the
slope life is hard life is good life is
enriched by complications and he seems
to feel so it should be a forest without
bears is empty thank you very much
thank you thanks thanks for that for
that close focused attention I
appreciate it let's uh questions
statements reactions please Carl yeah I
was wondering since you travel to all
these areas whether these experiences
between people predator or no large
carnivore interactions gave you some
perspective on how we live in the West
what we do right or what we do wrong
that may be different than what you had
before or what some of us have yeah I
hoped at the beginning that they would
give me a lot of perspective that I
could go to some of these places where
humans and big predators seemed to be
living together in kind of an uneasy
harmony or at least equilibrium and that
I'd find some some secrets that would be
useful to the rest of the world I didn't
find very many secrets because these
situations are all unique they're all
very different in terms of the
ecological circumstances for instance
saltwater crocodiles reproduce quickly
brown bears don't the socio-economic
circumstances of cultural circumstances
there are a lot of differences there are
maybe a few lessons that can cautiously
be extracted but I didn't come away with
any panaceas any any big answers that I
that I want to wave in people's faces
one of the things for instance though
that comes out of looking at the
Romanian situation is that if you have
large packs of really big nasty dogs you
can keep bears away from your sheep most
of the time they have a very different
way of of shepherding in Romania than we
have here it's very labor-intensive in
terms of in terms of human labor the
Shepherd's are out there there's lots of
shepherds they sleep with the Sheep out
on the on the high Meadows literally
wrapped up in a sheepskin I they don't
even walk 100 yards up to the cabin they
sleep out amid the flock and they've got
these big flock
big packs of truly ugly scary dogs that
seem to do a great job of running off
wolves and running off bear so that's
part of it the other thing that comes
out of most of these situations to at
least to my eye is that these people
don't have expectations of perfect
invulnerability from the dangers of the
world the people the mall dari in the
gear forests in India would tell me
things like well the lion is part of the
forest and we want to live in the forest
we don't want to live in Bombay we don't
want to live in the village this is this
is life this is the world and
occasionally we have to tangle with a
lion so be it that's we accept the costs
of doing business in this ecosystem and
there's this acceptance of a certain
degree of danger a certain degree of
loss that it seems natural to them that
that tends to take me into a larger
subject that I won't unravel completely
here but it's it's the idea of different
levels of tolerance for risk among
different kinds of people I think we all
have we all have our tastes in risk and
different groups of people are willing
to tolerate some kinds of risk and not
others and it's not it's not really am a
rational measure of how large the risk
is it's something that I think of as
flavors of risk that are acceptable to
some people and not others for instance
just and I'm dealing in stereotypes here
I realize but just forgive me that part
there are ranchers in the Northern
Rockies who find the risk of big
predators getting their livestock to be
unacceptable and those particular
ranchers would say the government should
get all these you know that's that's
what the predator control program should
be for we you know we should we should
be freed of all this risk that big
predators will attack our livestock they
find that particular type flavor of risk
unacceptable the same people might well
find other sorts of risk completely
acceptable for instance
driving a Ford pickup truck 70 miles an
hour on a dirt road without a seatbelt
that might be an acceptable form of risk
dipping snus smoking Marlboros also
entail risk those types of risk might be
acceptable to the very same people to
whom risk of predation on their
livestock by brown bear is unacceptable
now I don't feel like we should be smug
about that because conservationists
environmentalists green yuppies from
wonderful communities like Bozeman we
have our flavors of risk to we most of
us I suspect would find it utterly
intolerable to live downwind from a
nuclear power plant let alone a leaky
nuclear power plant that flavor of risk
is unacceptable to us we probably find
it unacceptable that there be red dye
number two and our maraschino cherries
and yet we'll walk out into a forest
where there are grizzly bears and we'll
hike in that forest and we'll know
there's risk and will say that's okay we
accept that risk that particular flavor
of risk is a flavor that we sort of like
or at least we're happy to tolerate
other forms of risk no intolerable so
it's it's human for different people to
be willing and unwilling to tolerate
different flavors of risk a long answer
to your question but anybody else
Valerie encounters or what was your
scariest experience with these predators
the I didn't have very many close
encounters I hope that I would when I
started researching this book I hope
that you know I'd have I mean every
writer as as Tim knows and others of my
colleagues here in the audience know
every writer goes out researching an
article or a book wants badly for lots
of interesting sub-lethal things to go
wrong
because that's where he gets stories so
I was hoping to be to be threatened
charged menaced by every possible big
predator of sublethal II and it didn't
happen very much partly because you can
spend a lot of time in these ecosystems
and not see big predators because
they're elusive and they're they're not
very abundant and partly I guess because
I was either lucky or unlucky I had some
some clothes but not tense encounters
with the Asiatic Lion I never did see a
Siberian tiger although I spent a lot of
time tracking them in the snow with some
biologists over there probably the
scariest thing that happened to me in
the course of researching this book
where's Lance there he is is as when
Lance craighead and I and a couple of
other fellows were hiking in a certain
area in yellowstone in i think it was
May just when bears are coming out of
hibernation and are really cranky and
hungry and we were looking for Grizzlies
and we walked over a little rise and
before we knew it Lance had turned
around is it okay to tell the story
Lance Lance had turned around and he was
ahead of us name is he back up back up
we said what wasn't he said there's a
sound grizzly with three cubs like 30
feet over this rise so we backed up
quickly and got out of her reign she
noticed us climbed up on a rock and and
her three cubs sort of did a while
linda's pyramid formation on her back to
look at us and and lance is saying to me
David David uncap your bear spray and
I'm thinking wait a minute you're the
one who's name is Craig head how come
I'm the only one who has bear spray
but she made her decision to to back off
and withdraw and not and not punish us
for that that little slip know anybody
else yes ma'am and I'm now thinking that
a backyard without any bears is empty
well sir maybe one more question if
there is one traveling and researching
for this book about three years
traveling and researching and a bet well
maybe two and a half four years
altogether traveling researching and
writing for years I thought it was going
to be a quick easy book as a change of
pace after the song of the dodo and and
before I knew it was for years what one
more um did sacrifice play a role in any
of the people that you came across and
in their lives I sacrifice of humans or
sacrifice of animals or animals humans
are animals not really among any of the
cultures that I've visited and got to
know close up there are there there are
some cultures in which sacrifice either
sacrifice of a human or sacrifice of an
animal is part of their relationship I
think it's the I knew in Japan who have
a relationship with the brown bear again
Ursus arctos I believe in Japan they
call it higuma and they venerate the
brown bear they also periodically
perform this ceremony where they capture
a bear cub a young bear cub they raise
it to the age of two or three and then
they kill it after having taken very
good care of it they kill it and they
call that sending the cub home and it's
some ceremonial part of their
relationship with this one with this
creature higuma there are probably a few
others like that but
among the cultures that I visited there
there was no real pattern or cultural
practice of sacrifice no okay one more
and then studied and written about
predators in Yellowstone Park and do you
know what is happening with the bear
population there is it increasing or
decreasing or I mentioned the Greater
Yellowstone situation a bit in the book
but almost only parenthetically for some
conscious reasons partly because I
generally make it my practice to to get
away from my my own home turf when I
write because I think I can see things
clearer and maybe penetrate a little bit
deeper if I'm not so close to the
situation culturally or ecologically but
all of this reflects back to Yellowstone
among other places the the habitat I
don't think the bears in Yellowstone are
are in particularly good shape I know
that there are those who believe that
the population has expanded
encouragingly in the last ten years or
so some people now make an estimate of
maybe 500 bears in the Greater
Yellowstone Ecosystem Grizzlies are hard
to count as you know so nobody really
knows other people say no we don't
really know that there's more than maybe
200 bears in the Greater Yellowstone
Ecosystem they just don't know meanwhile
our dear forest service particularly
under this administration continues
eroding bear habitat through their
timber practices in the national forests
of the Greater Yellowstone Ecosystem if
there even if there are 500 bears in the
Greater Yellowstone Ecosystem now and we
continue to lose habitat through erosion
of national forests decades of work in
conservation biology and Island
biogeography suggest that the
Yellowstone grizzly bear population is
teetering on the the cusp of being a
viable or non viable
halation and genetic terms and it's we
shouldn't feel particularly confident
about it even if even if we choose to
feel encouraged over some recovery in
recent years I don't particularly feel
too encouraged it's the habitat
continues to go but there are people in
this room who would be better at
answering the up-to-date scientific
particulars and policy details of that
question much better than I would okay
again thank you so much for coming out
and being such good audience
for the hospitality
david quammen is author of monster of
god the man-eating predator in the
jungles of history and the mind it's
published by WW Norton & Company on the
web at ww